[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to another
episode of the after show i'm your host
nikki novak and today
we're gonna be talking all things nope
we're going to be deep diving into the
movie and trying to answer some of the
burning questions that the film left
behind we have all the answers jordan
peele you know he doesn't give you all
the answers but we have them all today i
should warn you before you go any
further this is going to be a very
spoiler filled
discussion so if you enjoy that kind of
discussion having not seen the film well
then continue but if you don't then
watch the film and then come back and
join us
super excited to be talking with our
very special guest today
robert butler the third how are you
i'm great nikki how about yourself you
look amazing i love your hair i love the
on brand uh orange sweatshirt i hope you
appreciate my efforts as well
yeah i did peep i love the i love that
that's that's amazing this tells me a
little bit of something that we both
maybe liked the movie but we'll get into
it first i want to talk about what the
audience thought and the critics thought
the tomato meter score on this movie it
is certified fresh at 83 on the tomato
meter and the audience score a little
last 71 percent and here is the critics
consensus admirable for its originality
and ambition even when its reach exceeds
its grasp nope adds spielbergian
spectacle to jordan peel's growing
arsenal the box office it did great 44
million dollars domestically um but i
just wanted to sort of get a quick
reaction from you robert like what did
what do you think about the the tomato
meter score and the audience score being
a little bit lower i mean it's a
certified fresh score but do you concur
with both either in particular what are
your thoughts on that
i'm actually probably closer to the
rotten tomatoes score the critic score
um and even i would actually rate it a
little bit higher i really enjoyed this
movie a lot um i was actually one of my
favorite movies of the year but i can
also understand why cr why audiences
were not as enthusiastic about it
because it's not as commercially
appealing and the ending leaves you
wanting a little bit more so i can
understand why that scores a little bit
lower
yeah i i kind of get it too i've talked
to a few people that aren't in our
business and i think from um i think
maybe this is one of those cases where
as critics who see a lot of films and
there's a lot of ip out there there's a
lot of you know free franchises sequels
reboots everything that he does is
always
you know a one-off it's always really
its own thing but i think what people
are doing now is they're treating
because jordan peele has done three
featured films that he has directed
they're always horror so even though
they're not sequels people almost treat
them like sequels in a sense do you know
what i mean where they're comparing the
first to the second to the third movie
that he did and treating them kind of
like this is his own franchise and what
do we think about this latest entry um
and then i think there's some stuff with
the ufo that i'm gonna save to get into
why i think maybe the audience didn't
you know like it as much of the critics
um so just real quick what first what
what were the aspects of the film that
you think worked the best and is there
anything that you didn't think
worked just sort of briefly before we
get into our you know deep deep dive
um well i thought i thought for me i
loved a lot of the aspects of the film i
thought the craftsmanship of it from the
cinematography um the performances that
jordan pill was able to get out of his
lead actors daniel kahlua kiki palmer
and even uh the the new guy brendan
pariah yeah um he uh
he was he was a standout as well so that
we had a really really good time
establishing really great characters um
amidst a
horrifying
interpretation of alien invasion that we
honestly haven't seen before like we've
seen the ufo
that kind of shape portrayed in multiple
eras of sci-fi but we've never seen it
be a living organism that is you know
like actually eating people live and
eating horses and things of that nature
so i loved it i loved the meta
textualness of it don't i guess the the
one thing that i i didn't love upon my
first viewing of it was the ending um i
guess it felt a little anti-climactic
the first time i saw it but after
revisiting it the second time um upon
the second watch i actually do feel like
the ending resolved itself in a really
satisfying way
do you feel like i'm just gonna go for
it because the ufo
that turned into actually not being a
ufo the fact that it sort of started out
looking like a ufo
and then it turned into something
completely different do you think
because this is the thing about jordan
peels movies is you keep peeling back
layers upon layers and you're like oh is
this the meaning was that the meaning do
you think the fact that it sort of had
that traditional ufo look in the
beginning and then it revealed itself to
be something else was that an homage
to like close encounters or like typical
ufo movies that jordan peele was sort of
paying an homage or do you think that
was
within the context of the film do you
think it was the ufo
camouflaging itself in a way
that's a beast yeah
um i i definitely um i definitely think
it was the latter i think it the in the
beginning it was like camouflaging
yourself um because it it i think the
animal is a lot smarter than you know uh
then then a lot of the humans were given
the credit for and i think when it was
hiding itself in this like saucer form
uh it was you know demonstrating what
the traditional like alien kind of thing
will look like because that's probably
the form is taken in previous errors
but then when it reveals itself at the
end and it turns itself inside out i
think is trying to catch the character's
attentions because it knows um
as people look at it that's how it kind
of catches attention so i think it i
think in his own mind it transformed
itself
to be more beautiful and to be more
um to be more eye-catching so then you
know uh oj and and emerald would look at
it at the end i almost think in a way
too like
maybe the beast was smart enough that
when you think about history and
historically ufo movies
a ufo people sort of gaze at it they
don't try to take it down right but if
they see a creature
they will try to take it down and they
don't do that because when it's a ufo
and so it's disguising itself but it's
really it's creating this spectacle that
people stare at and then it's like
gotcha i'm actually something
but that would that was just my theory
um
what did you think okay so
did you feel like as for for me i didn't
everybody was talking about before i saw
the movie the big twist i didn't
necessarily find that to be a twist i
just thought it was sort of an element
of the film did you find it like was it
like a moment for you or
or no
so what so the twist and reference to
to the ufo being like a creature and not
an actual flying saucer
right right right i considered that more
of an element i think that really
connected the story to the gordy element
that we saw in the beginning um you know
it takes it takes the story from being
less about alien invasion and less about
uh you know the outsider mentality which
really a lot of older older school
sci-fi films when they had the alien
movie it was really a metaphor for
outsiders um you know if you want to go
to a greater extent like immigrants and
people who are outside of the norm of
societal uh
of society but in this kind of
reinterpretation it makes the alien more
of an animal more of a beast and more of
a savage beast and that's why we get
that gordy connection in the beginning
so i actually enjoy it being less of a
piece of technology as a ufo and more of
an animal because it makes it a lot more
it makes the the action and the horror a
lot more justifiable as opposed to the
traditional sci-fi you know constraint
of being like outsider the outsider
mentality why do you think jordan made
that choice
um i think he i think he's a
conscientious filmmaker i think he looks
at a lot of sci-fi and horror history
and looks at a lot of the mistakes of
you know the genre in the past and wants
to readdress that and i think he
addresses in a lot of ways when he talks
about animal cruelty which is the major
through line throughout the film overall
the idea of media sensationalism and the
consequences of that that to me is um
probably the one of the biggest themes
that i think a lot of people are are
lagging and when they when they
uh misinterpret the film and also
and also the theme of tokenism i think i
know that's the theme that we're going
to be talking about a little bit too but
how in
sci-fi and how in genre pictures in
general a lot of times the black
characters and the people of color are
kind of just washed off to the side i
think he's directly addressing that
when he's kind of putting
the the main characters as black people
in the forefront but also making the
alien
not something that is a metaphor for
um the traditional standard well he and
i also think it goes even beyond the
tokenism of black people but children
children being exploited in tv and
anything that
anything that can be commercialized
anything that can create a spectacle
that
we look at and
jordan peel and the thing that i thought
was the most brilliant personally about
this film is that jordan peele
can take something that's been happening
in the media or happening in in our
culture
and really nail it in such a in a way
that subverts your expectations like for
me
this whole society that we're in with
social media and getting the most
attention and getting the most likes or
even like
every day on twitter there has to be
something trending whether it's a
celebrity being cancelled whether it's
um
you know
politics no matter what it is we have
become addicted in a way
to what's the next big thing and what's
the next spectacle and in a sense
whether it's a good news story a bad
news story it's at somebody's expense
somebody is being exploited and almost
like
you know when you go towards the end of
the movie when stephen young is putting
characters putting on that show and
everybody who is a part of it who sort
of feeds into it buys that ticket looks
up in the air becomes a victim is a huge
statement i think
um so i think yeah that to me is the
thing that worked the best in this film
and i think that's what he is so
brilliant at it's like because i've been
thinking about that a lot and it's it's
like
even when somebody like a celebrity or
somebody passes away and everybody
writes tributes and then a week later
people don't talk about them or they
don't talk about them before they pass
like it's it's a whole bigger thing that
bothers me sometimes and i love that
jordan peele
really hones in
on
what is wrong societally and
without
there's no exposition in this film do
you know what i mean there's no
character sort of explaining things or
over explaining things and i think
that's also what jordan peele does so
well
is he doesn't he gives the audience a
lot of credit you figure this out for
yourself and if you have an
interpretation that you like it might
not be my intention but he he you know
he appreciates it because it opens a
discussion um okay so go ahead
oh no i was gonna say i think i think
that discussion angle is so crucial
because um he i think a lot of his
filmmaking is very intentional i think
he does leave easter eggs and leaves a
very clear pathway for where um he wants
his stories to go but at the same time
there are a lot of interpretations that
you can make about character motivation
about um who you know about uh the alien
the creature motivation um which is a
new element that honestly we don't
really uh talk about in a lot of sci-fi
films unless they're a little more high
brow like a rival or like a close
encounters or something of that nature
um but i also think you know when you
talk about that theme of like addiction
and media sensationalism um it i think
he does a brilliant job of showing it on
multiple generations like you said from
the kid actor um who stephen young's
character jup um from from a young age
to
the the the fry's guy initially in the
beginning but to a certain extent to the
transitioning to the tmz guy at the end
who literally puts his life on the line
to try and get that perfect shot and
then the cinematographer guy
voiced who you know sacrifices himself
for just the magic hour take two that
you know every dp wants to get so it's
super super fascinating how they touch
on that on how jordan pill touches on
that theme in so many different ways and
how he differentiates the character
morality from somebody like a dupe who
uses live animals and uses and and has
been using them to not even do the live
show but to test the live show for the
past six months where and he faces the
consequences for that like you said but
meanwhile someone like uh like darren
coleus character like oj he prefers to
use inanimate objects in the anima um
animals um and he you know benefits from
that and his k and his characters and
his family uh benefits from that you
know what's so funny is a lot of people
are are talking about how stephen
young's character kind of exploits
the animals but i kind of saw him more
as a victim because when you think about
it he was a child star right and and you
think about you we've heard of all these
child stars that later in life something
you know they have a hard time because
they get all of this attention and then
something happens and something happened
that was beyond his control you know
like something terrible happened on a
set and then he seemingly didn't work
again and he had this whole shrine
because that was sort of like his one
moment right like his one
claim to fame and the fact that there
was that line in there that some couple
paid like 50 grand to go and sleep in
and it was such a tragedy as it's
revealed later but the fact again that
people are so addicted to that spectacle
but i sort of saw him as a tragic figure
because i feel like he was just trying
to make ends meet he had a family of
three and then the poor guy was putting
like his own kids in the front of the
show like he he wanted to get his kids
in the business and you you sort of i
felt like what he did
i mean sacrificing the horses and that
was not cool but
i felt like he did it out of desperation
and again because he was exploited
yeah you know i i definitely i
definitely could see that angle of it um
i'm not sure how sympathetic the movie
was to him um simply because they they
did show in the beginning like he was
gonna have a whole reality show based on
um that live show experience right on
nbc um you know so he was really going
to milk it to the furthest extent and i
think i think the the kid you know it's
funny i you mentioned the kids i think
those kids were terrible those kids were
so not bad actors but just like bad ass
kids like who like why would they put up
the monkey costumes and and and go and
terrorize um um the their family farm i
know they stole they have stole that
inanimate like a horse or whatever the
metal horse but still that's some crazy
stuff and by the way what kind of
traumatic experience does jup have to go
through to where he puts his kids and
monkey outfits um to do the alien show
before uh before you know he experienced
that whole thing with the with gordy
like that's really really like to me i'm
like yo he he might just be you don't
feel bad for him like i do
yeah yeah i think he might just be
yeah yeah yeah okay but you said they
were terrible but i'm sorry that barn
scene was terrifying like when i was
when i saw that i thought that was what
the movie was going to be
i was like oh it's on when you saw the
little creature come out from behind the
thing i was like oh my god like jordan
peel's going to take us down a road
where he's going to show up some up cl
us some up close and personal kind of
like he did in us when the people come
to the door and you're like holy crap
it's not from afar it's not a spectacle
from afar it's in your face i was a
little bit disappointed that it didn't
end up being an alien because i thought
that would have been really really cool
but those kids nailed it in that scene i
mean they scared the crap out of me but
yeah when he brought them on later in
the quote-unquote show but um okay so
before we get go any further i i have to
ask the question
because everybody's ranking the jordan
peel movies they're comparing get out to
us i'm not necessarily asking you to
rank you don't have to if you want to
but how do you compare
this movie to his previous entries like
i said people are kind of treating it
his movies like sequels of each other
right and it's interesting i i talked
about this a little bit on twitter um i
think um i think this might be his best
directed film
and i think in terms of the scale in
terms of the magnitude and i think in
terms of the consistency between the
details i think especially upon the
second watch you really figure out
exactly how much every thread connects
to each other i think in in that respect
this his best directed film and but you
know there's no touch and get out like
get out's like a perfect screenplay in
terms of uh writing in terms of the
story that it's about and in terms of
the theme is trying to communicate it's
almost like a lightning in a bottle so
you can't really touch that uh in terms
of a writing sense but i i i do think
this is in terms of scale in terms of
magnitude and in terms of general
entertainment i've this is also the most
fun of having a jordan pill movie too so
i think it's his best directed and i
think it's his most ambitious and his
most fun and i do think overall maybe
get out is just a hair better but i
think over time you know nope is going
to grow a lot more on people i i
actually and i've made this argument
before that i always think it's really
hard when somebody has something that's
a breakout in the sense of we've never
seen anything like it before right and
so that's what get out was now let's say
this movie was jordan peele's first
movie and then we saw
this you know
um then we saw get out or then we saw
get out third i think we would judge
this movie by a different standard
because everything is always going to be
a comparison and when we've been been
desensitized it's like the first time we
saw his film we were like wow this is
that funny guy that we know from his
sketches and he's wow he's no tour
director
and so we kind of know his stamp now
it's always really different but we know
it's horror we know there's going to be
a twist we know there's going to be
themes so i think people are hard on it
i was i've seen it twice as well i was
the first time around
utterly riveted did not blink the whole
time i've heard some audiences say that
they found it slow and boring and that
they like the second half better than
the first half i actually like the first
half i think better than the second half
i love the way he creates suspense
nobody creates suspense the way he does
you think about get out us and nope you
think about the imagery you think about
i mean i have the scissors book behind
me like the book with the scissors like
the symbolism there's always a symbol
from every one of his movies there's a
theme with animals in every one of his
movies you know and
nobody is creating
things that we are talking about days
and weeks later like you saw scissors
after us came out you were terrified by
scissors right
the mess out of me right now so i can't
even look at
the sky are you looking to see if
they're moving
yeah yeah if there's if there's a
non-moving cloud like i'm definitely
getting so let me go to fries right now
and and get like the i don't even know
if fry still exists does fry's even
still i don't know but i did look up and
let's let's this just brings me or
bringing me right into our next sort of
topic and that is one of my favorite
things to dissect about jordan peel
movies that i don't pick out and i'm
gonna bring up some of the symbolism
in this film some of the easter eggs
some of the nods to other films or ever
other things that i have to read
articles frankly to sort of know but
fry's i is near universal where i think
he has an office and at least originally
the building had a ufo on the top
and
and so that was maybe something i like
it when directors and people draw from
what they know and what they see and
something that's meaningful to them so
maybe he drove by it every single day i
would love to ask him if that sparked
the idea for the film or what was the
the initial inception for the film but
um i thought that was sort of like a
brilliant little
um i also liked that that character like
you said he subverts your expectations
because when you first meet him you
think oh here's some dopey guy that just
works you know he just works you know
we've all seen that guy that offers to
come and set up our tvs in our house and
he ends up being incredibly clever
crafty
and then ultimately survives because of
the barbed wire which was just brilliant
that he was street smart
and so don't discount people because we
encounter people every single day that
we you know might you know the cashier
or whoever that we could just
not pay attention to but it's kind of
like that's making a statement as well i
think
yeah and i i think he's such a fun
character because he definitely and in
the beginning he definitely like d
downplayed oj and he in the haywards
like you know he was like trying to
explain to them the internet or whatever
um but then i i feel like as he was
installing the cameras he was kind of
justifying exactly what oj was talking
about like you know you know they
changed your name for ufos like he was
just such a he's just a real really well
developed character and yeah that move
at the end with the barbed wire was so
gangster because that's really i feel
like that was the move that transformed
the alien from being in this like more
contained um like flying saucer mode
into like going full out you know into
like is more colorful though because
yeah i think it got hurt by all that
sucking up all that barbed wire so yeah
and he i like too you like you said that
he didn't
like he didn't come to the house and go
wait what you they didn't make him that
cliche dumb guy like oh why are you guys
poning the cameras to the sky it was
kind of like oh i already know i already
know what you're doing i've already
researched this
and i know what's going on here and
guess what i'm also going to be a part
of it because i want you know he wants
maybe his cut too in the whole thing at
the end of the day um let's talk about
some of the other are there any other
easter eggs or sort of symbols or
references to films that you
particularly loved
um well yeah there's i mean there
there's a lot of uh easter eggs i mean
there's there's there's a ton right um
in terms in terms of references i mean i
know they referenced um oprah a lot um
and and with uh
getting that oprah shot there's a really
um infamous episode of oprah that they
had in like 2009 where um a woman had
got beat up by a chimpanzee i think her
name was like charlotte nash or
something like that and uh and i think
that was such a cool connection to
having that um
to having to sing to seeing how to
seeing that connection of
them trying to get the the oprah shot
and that's probably where the
inspiration for the champions he came
from was was was oprah from you know
jordan pill may be watching that oprah
clip so um i think that's incredibly
fascinating even if it was just for that
one-shot pay-off of um homegirl uh when
she
when we see her at the fair uh that was
that was really interesting yeah and i
liked you in the ads they showed her and
you kind of thought maybe she was going
to be one of the villains of the film
and she was actually one of the victims
again he kind of doesn't um and i think
her name
mary jo elliott there was there was a
reference
to
um
that was the name of somebody from e.t i
think so that was sort of like another
alien kind of like there's like a lot of
little easter eggs um did you so did you
think there was a bigger so do you think
there was a bigger meaning with the
because there was a lot of talk about
the oprah shot or i think it was to me
it was kind of like saying
you know everybody sort of wants that
ultimate fame or that ultimate
shot that ultimate because oprah in her
day when she had the oprah winfrey show
was just like
you know everybody wanted to be oprah or
be like oprah or achieve what oprah
achieved
yeah i mean i think that's i think
that's the ultimate i think that's the
ultimate guy i think jordan peel is very
smart about how we use his names right
because oprah is oprah is kind of seen
as the achievable um black figure in in
in our community or the achievable like
global sensation that everybody wants to
be the platform that everybody wants to
be on meanwhile oj's character is
literally named oj um and when he's on
set he kind of gets scoffed about it i
think that's another example of that
media sensation uh kind of getting in
the way of people's perception of them
because they just automatically
deride them and even in the beginning
when they're when they're outside with
them so i think that's i think you know
is somebody like you know somebody like
oj who wants to get to that that
ultimate pinnacle into the biggest
platform possible um and who hasn't had
who hasn't been able to have that
platform i mean it's symbolic of the
hayward family story the fictional
hayward family story to begin with how
there was a african-american or african
or bohevian horse writer on the first
pictures of the motion picture the first
widely circulated motion picture but
that never got any attention and even
though that is fictional it is crucial
that jordan pill highlights that and
shows that because you know like you
said jordan pillin of himself is a
franchise and he does have a dedicated
community of film lovers and cinephiles
who watch himself he's adding a new
piece of film history to the to the
lexicon and uh giving that a platform so
platforms are very important when
speaking on again those issues that we
we're speaking on like tokenism um and
the social justice
messages that jordan pills trying to
implement do you know what i thought was
gonna happen and i kind of wish that it
had not that i'm telling jordan peele in
any way shape or form how to end his
movies but because of that reference how
it was the first
um the first images captured it for a
motion picture but then the hayward
family kind of couldn't escape or
couldn't like rise above
like they just had you know they
couldn't sort of break out
um
i thought that it was going to end
because when they had daniel kaluuya
sort of sacrificing himself or oj
sacrificing himself saying i'm going to
be the one that's going to be the you
know
decoy for the um for the alien i thought
the shot they were going to get the shot
and it was going to be of daniel kaluyo
riding the horse with the ufo chasing
him and i thought that was going to be
the shot that was ultimately sold to the
media and then ultimately
it comes full circle from this being the
first images in hollywood that never
really got their due to all of a sudden
here is this black man riding this horse
and he is in a sense a hero because he
did finally get himself get the hero
shot i thought that's how it was going
to go but you know i'm always as i'm
sure you are when you're watching you're
like oh i know how this is going to end
you want to be the one to figure it out
right right and
and i think that's what's interesting i
think for me personally i think that's
the one major flaw i think the film
really has overall it doesn't really
have a great um resolution like it kind
of it has this climax and the climax
just kind of ends and it isn't a
beautiful place with them actually
getting that shot like with the from the
from the from the uh old circley whale
thingy from old picture thing but i do
think like we spent so much time in the
beginning with these characters we fall
so much in love with oj and emerald like
and you see their journey and you want
that gratification at the end like you
want to see them like you said i thought
they were actually like i thought oprah
was going to make a cameo or something
like at the end or um i don't know i
don't know what i thought but i thought
like yeah that they really at least we
had one more moment of that kind of
relief and that kind of and again i
don't i don't want to tell jordan peel
how to end his movies because he's a
brilliant filmmaker and i definitely get
why
it ends on that image because the film
starts on the image of gordy licking his
palms um in that animalistic state but
still kind of in that regret and but you
know he's kind of eating and licking his
palms meanwhile it ends on the image of
the alien like licking and about to eat
that giant balloon like in the sky so i
kind of get like that predator
connection that he's making and it's
really beautiful and powerful but yeah i
do agree like i do wish there was one
more
um one more image or one more scene that
kind of resolved that uh i heard
i heard somebody say they theorized that
daniel kaluuya's oj was actually dead at
the end because you sort of saw him
through the smoke and i'm like i totally
disagree i think he lived but i just
love that
this is sort of what the film does is it
doesn't give you all the answers and i
think sometimes people get frustrated if
they don't have all the answers but i
thought it ended i did i had zero issue
with the way it ended my biggest issue
with the film was that i didn't find the
ufo scary i wanted the ufo to be scary
and to me i mean the image yeah when it
was sucking people up through its
intestines or whatever whatever you want
to call that
that was terrifying of course but the
image to me of the of the ufo
especially when it opens up again was
kind of
it kind of was beautiful right like it
was beautiful and then that square thing
that came out that i didn't get this to
the second viewing that maybe that was
supposed to represent a camera
because it was so um
geometric and the way it kind of popped
out it was almost like that
old-fashioned camera that they used to
have back in the day
um that that was a symbol and so then
i'm like i get it and i think there's a
whole maybe meaning behind because i'm
sure like i've talked to so many people
that are like oh i love the design of
the ufo and i was like i just wanted
something almost gruesome and creepy and
something like it was almost it didn't
look like a ufo so do you think like
if we're sort of saying like okay beyond
where the film ends do you think if they
take that shot that they got that kiki
palmer's character got and take it
somewhere how are people gonna react to
it do you think people are going to buy
it what do you think what do you
theorize happens after
well i i mean i personally think well i
i do agree i think it was beautiful and
i really think um i think that was the
point right i think it was i think he
wanted to take a a figure that most
people would associate with fear like an
alien or like a an unearthed creature
and make it this kind of gorgeous piece
but still make it do like terrifying
actions and still have it you know be a
world eater and a soul sucker and things
of that nature um but yeah i do think
like i wonder yeah if when that picture
comes out to the public what the
reception would be because we do know
even though kiki palmer was like you
know by herself when she uh set off
those balloons the news people were not
too far behind her so i'm sure they got
a good look at a lot of the situation
that was happening too at least from
afar um at least that's my my prediction
my theory right so i i at least hope
that um i think that people would like
freak out and people would be
um
super crazy about it but also i don't
know if people would believe it i don't
know people since there wasn't like a
lot of footage like that's that's kind
of the unfortunate part about why the
cinematographer dude i think his name
was hoist he kind of ended up
sacrificing himself at the end because
they had that great imax footage that
they got
of a lot of that chase we ended up
losing that to the wind because of his
uh because of his own ego so i guess
that was people are saying that him
sacrificing himself is kind of a jaws
reference in a sense but like i that
part i didn't i didn't love because i
was like
i didn't see enough of his character to
know why he was suddenly sacrificing
himself for the shot it just seemed so
kind of he was this like cool calm
collected i like actually really loved
his delivery um but i i don't know that
all of a sudden he kind of wigged out i
thought for a second he was under the
influence of the ufos kind of like the
way maybe it was alluded to like how
gordy freaked out or he freaked out but
then
upon second viewing i was like no he
made it he made a conscious choice i
thought it was a little bit corny in my
opinion the way maybe it was just i
don't know maybe i needed to see more of
his character arc to understand why he
was doing that um but i thought he was a
great actor i wanted to ask you the
one-eyed one-year flying purple people
eater that he speaks it's a song that he
speaks it in a really slow kind of
monologue
do you know that song because i feel
like
maybe a younger generation
won't know that song
[Laughter]
younger than me because yeah i totally i
totally remember singing that as a kid
and i don't even know what it's from or
why but that was um what did you think
of the sunglasses at night speaking of
music and sort of his choice of songs
like the corey heart
um yeah yeah what did you think of some
of the music choices and the score
well i thought i thought all of the
music uh was phenomenal i thought it all
played to the to the to the themes of
the film like you said sunglasses night
when they're literally like at night and
we're seeing rays and um you know uh
all sorts of light and we actually see
um jupe testing the show from afar um in
the beginning which is like super super
interesting um and then yeah i i love
um
yeah i love the score too because it
definitely had horror themes in the
beginning but it played into the western
theme a lot too which i think made it
feel a lot
more authentic um to what you know
because
there isn't a lot of like westerners
hollywood westerns anymore especially
like modern ones contemporary ones i
found like this i think this movie had a
really creative way of instituting a lot
of like great western aspects like
through the music like through um you
know through the horse riding obviously
did a reference of the scorpion leave
the reference of the orange sweater that
was from the scorpion king crew but i
feel like is like resemb like resembles
a a like a like almost like a a soldier
going into into battle not soldier but
like a cowboy about to go into his long
ride or whatever um like
you putting his uniform on so i really
dug a lot of those aspects of it and i
thought it was um yeah i think i think
i think
in regards to how the music kind of
swept over
um the film i thought it made the pace
really work too because like i thought a
lot of people were criticizing it for
being slow in the beginning i didn't
think it was slow in the beginning at
all in fact i think the music really
helped bring that pace and that like
kind of um that kind of rhythm that i
thought like elevated the movie there
was a stillness to it and hoyt van
hoytuma the cinematographer is so
brilliant like
the world that they created
and those night shots as terrifying as
that was i want to go live on that ranch
for a while i want to go hang out there
i want to spend time there i want to
take walks along the road
without the aliens but like
they captured and and i think i've heard
people talk about how difficult
capturing those shots at night are and
you've never really seen you know
because a lot of it was shot on imax
you've never seen such an expansive view
of things at night that the way you
would see that shot with the house lit
up in the back and the windows were so
perfectly lit up i thought he and jordan
worked so well together to create a
world that you wanted to spend more time
in
and it makes you comfortable right like
even though it's uncomfortable what
happens you want to sort of just hang
out there with them um which kind of
leads me into the performances because
daniel kaluya and kiki palmer
they're so brilliant in my opinion and
what's so brilliant about the way these
characters were developed was how these
brother and sister were completely
opposite of each other and the thing
that i find
that from the first time i've seen
daniel kahlua on screen what i love
about him i love actors that are
confident enough to under play things
and to have to trust and have enough
going on under the surface that they're
going to be interesting like the fact
that he kind of under under-reacted to
the aliens and under-reacted to
everything made him a hero to me in a
sense right
and then you had her
who
stole so many see talk about steam
sealers but i actually thought they
balanced each other perfectly because
she had so many funny moments and people
were laughing out loud both screenings
that i that i saw
but
i think that was
um other than just jordan peele having
these great messages in his films those
two were excellent what did you think
their chemistry was next level and i
think i really do think yeah there is
nobody else you could have cast in those
part other than danny kaluuya and kiki
palmer um especially kiki palmer she's
had such an amazing career throughout
her entire life even from when i was
watching her as a kid on true jacksonvp
um aquila and the b was one of my
favorite movies growing up uh so like
she she's had a stellar career which i'm
so happy and you know she's been on mad
talk shows and things of that nature i'm
so happy to see her kind of now have a
number one movie at the box office i
mean it really speaks to um her talent
and i think she i think
you know like you said like with o.j
he's a lot more stoic he's definitely
especially in the beginning when we have
that hilarious scene on the movie set um
where he's trying to explain the the
safety meeting during or he's trying to
explain the rules during the safety
meeting and he just can't barely even
vocalize beyond like um like a mumble
but meanwhile she gets on set
immediately is ready to like talk and
yeah and i i appreciate that energy
because you can see
the connection you can see like the
differences like you can see that
oj had a lot deeper connection to his
father with keith david um in the
beginning and that loss hurt him a lot
more than probably affected kiki
palmer's character emerald um but
meanwhile she's dealing with that grief
in her own way because um she's been
pretty disconnected from the family
she's talking about going to therapy and
how she's dealing with the traumatic
like you know not necessarily dramatic
but the that her losing jean jacket um
you know in the beginning what
when she was a young child
that memory kind of ends up sparring her
and that is ultimately i think fueling
her motivation for pershing forward at
the end and o.j wisely knows that and
and recognizes that connection with her
with his sister yeah it's almost like
and he wants to keep the ranch going
he's very sort of like keep that
generational thing going pay homage pay
respects to his ancestors where she's
like sell it sell it like you know she
sort of calls him an idiot in the
beginning like when stephen young's
character offers to buy the whole ranch
she's like
how much and you know like obviously
you're not even kind of considering it
kind of thing where you should but then
i think tour i think she has a great
character art the thing that i love
about kiki palmer and i've interviewed
her before several times is there's a
lot of actors that don't like to be
interviewed because they like to
disappear into a character but the thing
that's so great about kiki she is larger
than life she is such a great
personality
that
it's it's it's cool that she didn't try
to sort of like take away from all that
she is she kind of put it all on display
in this film right like she has so much
energy and like that sort of je ne sais
quoi that like extra special like spark
um
that that he was able to write a
character for her that so was so perfect
for her to sort of showcase her talent
and now like think about how many years
and this is again kind of mind-blowing
because in a sense she's been doing this
she's almost like that child actor that
we saw in the film but she's the one
that sort of
persevered and did things the right way
and all these years later she's getting
her due because of this film which is so
crazy
you know yeah and i
and i do think yeah i think her energy
is magnetic and i do think when you
especially talk about the arc of the
film she is the the central through line
right because when um oj he he doesn't
really
have he's pretty much like you said he
wants to stay at the farm all the way
through and through she doesn't and she
really actively
uh wants to get rid of and move as far
away from that legacy as possible but
learning about the legacy of the farm
and i think learning about um the
historical impact of being the first you
know black uh
black film you know the first films on
stars because she's watching that tape
like by herself multiple times so she's
kind of getting that history when she's
back at the haywood farm herself like
she seemingly has been so disconnected
for a minute that she hasn't been around
so i like that she eventually comes
around she says no to sticking around
multiple times right like she says no
she refuses you know in the hero journey
story they talk about the refusal to the
call she refuses to call multiple
multiple times but at the end she
ultimately gets that hero shot which
makes this so much more gratifying which
i love that you know some people are
like oh why does um she gets to you know
kill the alien at the end why wasn't it
him or was it you know wasn't it like
you know the military something like
that i love that it was her because it
felt
it felt like
she needed she needed that like she her
character was
like you know doing a lot of different
jobs you know kind of aimless and really
going for the shot for the pursuit of
like money and personal benefit but it
felt like it was just a gratification of
like saving the world and saving her
brother and saving you know the the
entire ranch was just an amazing
expression she did such a good job in
that moment as an actress okay so you
just reminded me of something so
you know in the when they finally do the
reveal of the monkey scene and what
happens on set he comes over
to
the little boy and gives him a fist bump
and he spares him he's kind of like
you're my kind of like the chosen one
like i'm not going to do anything to you
do you think it came full circle because
we don't really see we think at one
point that daniel cooley's character oj
is killed by the alien because he looks
right up at it because he's like come
and get me while you go escape to his
sister so he is a hero in a sense too
right like he's kind of sacrificing
himself but then why is he spared
because he looked directly at it and he
was like come get me and then he's
telling her to go go go get on that
motorcycle so i felt like that was
for some i felt like the alien chose
to save him and leave him alone because
he felt that beautiful energy that he
was trying to protect the horses in the
beginning that he wasn't trying to
capitalize on things that oj's character
was doing things the right way and so he
was spared kind of like the little boy
was do you agree with that
um yeah i think yeah i think i think to
some extent you know and it was
interesting with
with the gordy scene with that with the
balloon popping um obviously it was a
connection to when the balloon pops um
at the end with the alien um but also if
you notice carefully when when gordy's
kind of looking at his hands and and
at the end after that last pop that he
hears um he does a little bit of sign
language and his sign language is saying
like hey family like what's up like what
happened like he he's looking around
like in confusion so he was in so it
seemed like when he was on his like kind
of terri when the monkey was on this
kind of like tyrannical state and
beating everybody up he was kind of
almost like brainwashed in his own kind
of delusion but i think by the end of it
he did snap out of it and did go back to
being his traditional chimp kind of self
um so i do kind of wonder like maybe
that maybe that's something that
happened to the alien or maybe the alien
um wanted bigger wanted a bigger bait
out of uh from you know from chasing m
because i feel like i feel like the
alien kind of enjoyed the challenge a
little bit too like i think i think i
think he didn't like the fact that
daniel khalia was just kind of staring
him down like waiting for waiting for
something to happen like i think um i
think the fact that
um
emerald was about to get away and she
called out like hey like right before
she um drove off into the working
motorcycle like i think that kind of
motivated the thing like okay i'll come
back to dan kaluy later but let me go
take care of her and then ultimately
when she unleashes the things the aliens
like oh this is the biggest mill i could
get look at this giant little uh this
little uh
sheriff boy i could i could definitely
eat that up but it didn't work out um
what did you think of the the blood rain
that you reminded me of that too like
that was obviously a shining reference
like i think there were some you know
like there's so like you said so many i
felt that it felt like a very different
tone like that felt like very bloody
gory like the you know
like the red room kind of thing and that
was less you know than less sci-fi it
was more that traditional horror and i
think he sort of jumps
um
between genres a little bit
yeah and i think yeah i think at that
point the alien was kind of
intentionally messing with the the
family because you know he throws the
the inanimate horse right into the car
that he's in uh which i don't i don't
think was i don't think was an accident
i don't think the i don't think he like
he could have poured that blood down in
anywhere he landed specifically over
that house i think at that point the
alien knew that you know uh they were
kind of messing with him and it was kind
of like playing chicken and mouse
throughout the entire movie so um at
least that's how i interpreted it and i
honestly i think that's why
you know like
he i think the alien was so used to
somebody like a juke trying to tame it
and trying to you know um get in the way
of it and trying to
get to know his actions and and control
it but he wasn't the alien wasn't used
to somebody like oj who wants who
understands the animals a lot more
understands their natures and knows like
working around them so um he definitely
i think the alien was like by the end
like you said when he stares down um o.j
at the end he's like okay maybe you are
like a decent person maybe you're not
necessary um
because i think he's been acting like i
think the alien was actively paying
attention to i think i think jean jack
was actively playing interesting
throughout the entire movie interesting
i didn't think i didn't think about that
cat and mouse game that they were kind
of playing throughout until you just
pointed that out
like yeah
yeah
i think that's i mean i i feel like
especially because it stayed in the area
for so long and we we know that alien
was coming from a different location
before because uh it came
you know it was um puking out a bunch of
the metal stuff that it didn't like and
that's what ultimately killed key david
so it came from another location
previously but why did it stick in this
area for six months it's because it's
all jew you know constantly feeding your
horses and and and wanting that
interaction but when it when they when
jean jacket saw drew trying to exploit
it he thought time was up but yeah i
think he i think the the alien was more
than conscious i think it was almost
like sentient and keeping an eye over
this whole little part of the outskirts
of l.a what did you think of um speaking
of jupe what did you think of stephen
young's performance
uh he was amazing the one scene that
stood out to me was when he was
describing the young gordy scene and he
was particularly talking about the fake
snl episode um i thought to me to me
that was such a
brilliant like setup
payoff um and just seeing the way he
kind of had this chilling kind of almost
like he relished the memory like he was
almost like um nostalgic about it for
some extent but also like quietly
terrified too like i don't know i
thought his his performance was so so
good like beyond for even the small part
that he had i can almost see it being
like almost seen stealing as well so
i've heard so much criticism about that
part but i think stephen young tends to
a spit similar to daniel under play like
that could have been a very
like mustache twisting evil
character that sort of outwardly showed
you how calculated he was but i think
you're right like he almost has that
what's like when people are kidnapped
and then they have that syndrome where
they
um are attached to their capture it's
almost like in a sense like he was oh
like stockholm likes him
like he was traumatized by what happened
but then he was addicted to it in a way
because maybe that was his sort of
biggest
claim to fame or his most you know
exciting moment in that in the business
that people still talked about it was
the only thing that people talk wanted
to talk about with him right exploding
the exploding handshake and then it's
crazy because he marketed he seems like
he's seemingly marketing himself all
around that other property that he was
in right kid sheriff or whatever but
yeah it's almost like nobody you know
there's not a lot of people at that park
there's seemingly like not a lot of
people going um talking about that but
everybody wants to talk about gordy like
nobody's trying to get a 50 000 picture
of him and the kids sheriff stuff but
everybody wants to talk about gordy's
home so he's using that as like his new
play in his new angle for relevancy and
ultimately faces the consequences for it
but yeah i do think like i don't think
he's an outwardly evil character and i
do think you're right i think to some
extent he is a victim and i think jordan
peel's very careful not painting anybody
as a specific evil or as a specific good
guy and i think uh especially his
character like i don't think he has the
most malicious intense he just doesn't
have the same sense of morality and you
know in all honesty he probably thinks
um you know uh uh in all honesty
drew probably thinks that he's the one
who calmed gordy down to begin with
right like he thinks he has a special
connection to animals um he thinks
that's the reason why gordy didn't kill
him he thinks that's something to do
with him he thinks oh gordy hurts
everybody else but not me i must be
great i must be special and it's that
ego that drives him to you know thinks
that he could keep treating animals a
certain type of way that ultimately
leads to his demise so what the heck did
the shoe mean what did the shoe mean the
shoes standing up
yeah a lot of theories about a lot of
things and a lot of easter eggs and
nobody has come up with the answer to
what the shoe means
yeah i to me the only the only thing i
could really take from that is maybe you
know how when you have a bad dream or a
bad memory and you have one thing in a
and a memory that you just know doesn't
make sense or just no you know doesn't
really work out that way or it didn't
happen that way but it just sticks out
in your mind for some reason that to me
that was just my interpretation of it
like he that was maybe something of him
processing his trauma in a certain type
of way that um you know maybe maybe it
was unique to him but i don't know if
that i don't know maybe it didn't
actually happen it was his memory as a
kid where like people embellish things
in their brain like there was a shoe it
must have been supernatural because
there was a shoe that was standing up
and maybe the shoe wasn't even standing
up
right exactly that's that's the way i
kind of looked at it but i don't know i
that's the only that's the only reason
because there's nothing there's not a
lot in the film that kind of gives you
an answer towards that right so i don't
know what i really don't know what else
to say i don't know i've been trying to
figure out too because i heard jordan
say in an interview people have asked
him if he's ever going to connect the
get out world to the us world to the
nope world if they exist in the same
universe and he won't talk about get out
existing in the same universe but he
said us and nope exist in the same um
universe
that there's an easter egg in the movie
that if you are really nerd out and you
really watch it so on my second viewing
i was so determined to figure out what
the tie-in was i was looking at the
posters on um
on the wall when they go to um
to um jup's
office i was like maybe there's a poster
on the wall or there's a reference to
something that happened that was a
parallel to something that happened i
can't figure it out so i'm just putting
that out for there for you
to think about it and try to figure out
what it is he hasn't said what it is i
would just personally say to anybody
sort of who has a criticism of about
anything um to do with this film and
sort of like it didn't sort of
it wasn't what they expected in a way um
because it doesn't follow i get really
sick of formulaic movies
especially because you know you and i
both see a lot of movies it's kind of
what we do i
applaud
anybody who is doing something so
original and so fresh and so different
than what's out there and i think it's
almost like maybe for maybe when you're
watching a lot of stuff and you're like
oh this this wasn't what i expect i i
expected it and even as an audience
member because i can criticize the ufo
i'm like oh i expected it to be this i
was disappointed but maybe with time and
and even in the second viewing i
appreciated it more than than in the
first viewing that it's because it
doesn't feed into
what
you know what you would expect you
expected a gory kind of thing
and you didn't get it and i just hope
that
jordan
explains more down the road about a lot
of his films and gives us more answers
and i hope that he
i hope he ties the worlds together i
think it would be really awesome to see
him tie all these worlds together um so
before i let you go thank you so much
for joining this was a really fun
conversation and please give yourself a
plug where people can find you
uh yeah you can find me on twitter and
instagram director rb3 and you can find
me on youtube on first cut um where we
do movie reviews podcasts things of that
nature and you can follow our social
medias as well first at first cut tmo on
twitter instagram and tick tock
rb3 you're awesome i loved chatting with
you this is a great time thank you so
much for joining and thank you all for
joining and we will see you on the next
episode of the after show
bye
[Music]
you